a young man walks beside a girl across a
flowered field spring has come and this
girl is his life he prays a child climbs
a tree to watch the sunset over the
fields summer is ending and the harvest
is life for his village he prays a
hunter tracks a boar through the woods
winter is coming and they swore his life
for his family he prays but to whom do
they pray the world has as many answers
as there are men to answer but walk far
enough climb high enough hunt long
enough and a man shall find only one one
God with many faces in the faith of the
seven he is the stranger who guides men
from this life to the next few seek his
favour or at least if you realize that
they do in the north of Westeros he is
one of the nameless old gods staring out
from the weirwood trees and the snow in
the Iron Islands
he is the drowned God calling men down
to his watery Hall what his dead may
never die but rises again harder and
stronger in the Far East he is the Lion
of night
who fathered the world's first emperor
on the made made of light and whose
wrath nearly ended the world in volantis
he is the lord of light whose followers
feet men to the flames to beg his favor
in lys he is the weeping lady who sheds
her tears for the living soon to die in
qohor he is the black goat and he feeds
on blood offerings every day and holy
days he has offered condemned criminals
and in times of great crisis he may even
be offered the nobles children of the
city to beg his protection does he
accept their gift well the city still
stands
for the poor he's the hooded Wayfarer
for soldiers
he is back alone the pale child for
sailors
he's the moon pale maiden and the Merlyn
King in the house of black and white
however he is all of them and none of
them he is the many-faced God and
wherever a man turns there he is men
come from every corner of the world to
know him to beg his favor and seek his
gift for themselves if their life has
grown too hard or for others who are
making it so it is all the same to the
many-faced God Valar dohaeris all men
must serve him beggars and kings while a
morghulis all men must die
good and evil men worship as they will
but at the end of every road stands the
many-faced God waiting